the first time I ever got a $10,000
check in a week in my entire lifetime or
ever made $10,000 in a month and I'm on
the computer and I'm like oh my gosh I
said I just made $11,000 this week I'll
give you the date it was May 29th of all
four I made $11,000 that week and I'm at
18,000 for 95 in a month of May of 2000
and for the first time ever on my life I
made eighteen thousand four ninety five
minutes single month do you know what
happened you know why that happened
because beginning of that year six
months prior to that I made a decision
that I truly want to find out what
you're capable of if you fully focus and
here's what I've learned any time of my
entire life
I've been 100% focused I've always want
any time you have as well by the way so
if you think about yourself go back at
any time in your life Stephanie the
focus for 12 months 18 or 24 months
guarantee you one because it's a formula
and I know most people weren't going to
do it I know most people get discouraged
I know most people would get to scratch
down and mostly we're going to say I
have voice on issues Group finishes
family issues health issues market
issues this isn't funny I don't know if
this it's not my passion it's all this
stuff that they make up because they
simply don't want to do the work because
they're frightened of the work now you
I'm talking to you you don't have to be
that you don't have to be one to do a
staff listen I wish there was a way for
you to come into my mind and go through
the entire history and see how many
times I almost quit and I almost thought
I couldn't do this business because I
wasn't smart enough I didn't have the
market I didn't have people who believed
in me everybody doubted me everyone I
touch things like they don't want to buy
from you or did we quit and I was so low
self-esteem deloused insecure like truly
I did not feel like to do this business
I wish you could come and live in this
thing
for five minutes to get all the history
to realize and to believe me I almost
gave up on this thing
I almost went back for $75,000 your job
I almost gave up on this thing I I
almost gave up on this thing I was this
close I almost give up on this thing I
almost give up on this thing but at one
point I stood up I said I'm going 24
100% focus I am NOT going to get
distracted I don't share about the party
I'm not going to be chasing skirts cause
I would single I don't care about TV I
don't care about TV shows I'm sure about
the radio I don't care about any of this
stuff and you know what happened I
thought it was going to take 24 months
to know if this works it works 90 days
late or 90 days later I made 18,000 for
95 I just love the skinny I mean I love
what this does world life and a person
and a waiter I love it I love what it
does and so can you
if you focus this isn't just a
commercial for you so can you if you can
stay focused I just hope you make the
decision you if you make the decision to
stay focused entire year no distractions
none of that stuff scares focus as
possible